there's a phrase that gets thrown around
a lot these days particularly in the
longevity space and that phrase is
cheeky science
but there's another word you may also
hear about and that is epigenetic
reprogramming
I'm guilty myself of throwing this word
around without really explaining what it
means while I've discussed reprogramming
before
I wanted to discuss in this video what
it's really meant by the phrase
epigenetics and it goes beyond me do you
really know what's meant by that term
well hopefully by the end of this video
you will have at least my interpretation
of this term
and in particular I will focus mainly on
the link between epigenetics gene
expression and cell identity what makes
a happy healthy cell do what it does
best
and I think by the end of it you will
have three main take-homes one an
appreciation of genome organization and
cell identity
two an overview of the different classes
of epigenetics and three the sort of
modern day look at things and epigenetic
reprogramming
now my epigenetic journey began when I
read this book about eight years ago but
instead before you go running off to the
bookstore I think it's better we start
with a little bit of maths you see
within each of our cells we have three
billion base pairs of DNA so the A's T's
C's and G's given that each base is 0.6
nanometers in length if we multiply that
by 3 billion we end up with 1.8 meters a
number we can actually process
and so you know that's about two meters
of DNA and that's got to get not just
into each of our cells but into the
nucleus of ourselves
so like imagine the tallest person you
know and then imagine them stood on some
stilts and then that length getting
squashed not only into one cell but into
the nucleus of one cell
so how well it's not just scrunched up
into a ball and like another job well
done but it's also not a rigid
architecture perfectly aligned to every
nanometer
that's not to say it's a mess
it's highly structured and organized yet
it is dynamic it can be changed
what that is all meant to say is that
the 3D organization of how this DNA is
packaged is important and so here it
goes firstly the DNA is wrapped around
proteins called histones which form
structures called nucleosomes and we can
also call this as chromatin
now this works because these histane
proteins have an abundance of positively
charged amino acids which attract them
to the negative backbone of DNA
what's at an uncompacted level looks
like beads in a string can then get
coiled folded and looped to form more
compressed layers of Chromatin which are
further packaged to form chromosomes we
have 23 pairs of chromosomes and all of
these undergo this packaging process
and while you can draw these chromosomes
out in a linear manner due to this
folding it means that regions that are
far away can actually interact you're
just not thinking fourth dimensionally
right right I have a real problems well
at least three-dimensionally for now
and each chromosome can be mapped and it
has been observed that each of them has
its own territory
another point to reinforce is that this
process is not homogeneous there are
some parts of Chromatin that are more
open and some parts are some more
tightly repressed
so there are some highly interacting
carbs like a city and other areas where
less contacts are made
but what are the implications of this
packaging well packaging does indeed
come with consequences
DNA with our genetic information is now
tightly packaged into the nucleus
brilliant but the more tightly you DNA
is packaged our penis chromatin the less
accessible the DNA sequence becomes and
DNA has our information for example DNA
is important for transcription the
initial stage of gene expression the
Machinery that facilitates this process
needs sequence specific information to
ensure that it initiates at the correct
place
and so depending on which regions are
more open therefore influences why gene
expression is more likely to happen what
genes are expressed influences what the
cell does and therefore what identity we
give to the cell be it by calling it a
neuron or a skin cell
so this begs the question of how is it
decided what areas are more open and
more compressed and while decided isn't
a good word for me to use her instead I
prefer the phrase what are the
regulatory mechanisms in place and what
does one refer to as these mechanisms
well evidently there is additional
information that goes beyond the DNA
sequence that is required as all cells
in our body have the same DNA sequence
yet they are expressing different genes
and so this brings us back so trying to
Define epigenetics
so to just give a definition of
epigenetics then it says heritable
information that can be found on top of
the genomic sequence and those marks are
modifiable
key for interpretation here is the white
Heritage Pool and for the remainder of
this video we'll look at some of these
types of epigenetic marks and how they
are modifiable so the first class of
epigenetic marks we'll look at are
modifications to these histone proteins
thus were involved in packaging DNA into
the nucleus
these histone proteins have tails and
these Tails can undergo various
modifications such as acetylation and
methylation
these are just chemical modifications
that can influence the compaction of
chromosome and the accessibility of DNA
sequences for transcription
for example acetylation of histones is
generally associated with more open
chromatin structure and increased
transcription while methylation can lead
to more compact chromatin and decrease
transcription a minor cell replicates
not only is DNA replicated but these
histone proteins are also displaced new
proteins are made and then they're
reincorporated but the new histine
proteins must also regain these
epigenetic marks I won't go into the
mechanism here but the appreciation is
that these marks are indeed heritable as
a cell divides they can also be modified
by other proteins that can add or remove
these different modifications
another epigenetic modification that
involves methylation that influences how
genes are expressed isn't on histone
proteins but on DNA itself
this is referred to as DNA methylation
and when it comes to longevity you've
most likely already heard of it and so
DNA methylation is cool and complex
although well no not quite the
complexity of histo modifications
as hair it mainly refers to methylation
of the cytosine the C residue of DNA
most of these marks are seen when
cytosine is adjacent to guanine G in
ourselves we have a sort of bimodal
landscape of these marks where there are
sites where there are low density of
these CG sequences and they tend to be
methylated whereas high density regions
called CG Islands tend to be not
methylated so hypomethylated and then
looking at the presence or absence of
methylation at some of these sites has
been seen to correlate with age which is
what you may have heard of in terms of
epigenetic age or DNA methylation age
tests and I've shown them in different
videos before
but the caveats at the moment which
we'll come back to later more generally
it started as unclear what these marks
are doing and how the cell reads the
information of DNA methylation
but generally speaking methylation of
course changes the chemistry of the base
and hence what proteins combine to
certain regions how package the
chromatin is and as we've already
discussed what genes are subsequently
going to be expressed
so it's another class of epigenetic Mark
and then the third class of epigenetic
marks are rnas this is probably the
coolest area of epigenetics I mean I'm
joking they're all pretty cool but these
rnas have been of particular interest
for understanding transgenerational
information inheritance
but I will briefly skim over its hair
because there are many types of rnas
from small rnas to long non-coding rnas
and hence there are many different
mechanisms in which they can influence
gene expression but broadly speaking
these rnas can interact with protein
components that affect gene expression
both at the level of DNA packaging but
also about the messenger RNA level a
stage of gene expression during
translation
RNA can also directly bind RNA or DNA
due to complementary base pairing and so
this enables site-specific regulation
and another feature is that these rnas
many of them hang out in the cytoplasm
of all places and because they're in the
cytoplasm they can get passed on for
your cell division like how many other
organelles like mitochondria are passed
on
hence why it's also been of interest for
understanding transgenerational
inheritance
so those are the three main classes of
epigenetics protein-based dna-based and
rna-based and these dictate cell
identity well apart from the one obvious
tiny little baby little hiccup what
actually dictates what marks the
presence and where their presence like
why should lysine 26 of histone protein
3 at genemic Locus chromosome 6 165 700
BC slated
well there are proteins that modify
these marks and they can get recruited
to genomic loci through interacting with
current epigenetic marks and other
proteins banned at that site but this
what comes first cause first is
consequence is still undetermined in the
fields but since while at Elizabeth Long
got on these chromatin modifiers that
now brings us full circle to touch upon
epigenetic reprogramming since I
mentioned it at the start of the video
for the case of going to a stem cell
from a skin cell one can employ the
so-called yamanaka factors these are
four transcription factors that by
influencing gene expression can
reprogram the set of epigenetic marks
presents how exactly again is not
understood fully and one could talk
about whether transcription factors are
more important than epigenetic marks
which leads us onto Pioneer
factorizability and ultimately I could
talk about p53 for half an hour if you
wanted and while I joke around as usual
and make it sound like we know how all
this stuff works this really is sort of
the cutting-edged off at the moment of
what scientists are trying to do
and that's been fueled by some pretty
good advances in the tools used to make
these discoveries thanks to Next
Generation sequencing Technologies and
some very clever assays such as high C
Crimson capture chip sequencing attack
sequencing and the ability to also need
this on a single cell level
that said we tend to study these marks
in isolation whereas there is much
interplay across these different types
of epigenetic marks but I hope this
video has given you a better
understanding of what epigenetics is and
that hopefully you can agree with me
that it is fascinating plus it also
relates somewhat to my mphd work and
given that I also think small rnas are
fascinating perhaps I will touch upon
transgenerational epigenetics in an
upcoming video well maybe we'll see but
in the meantime you can learn about
epigenetic reprogramming hair so with
that thank you to my patreon supporters
and thank you for listening